let's go - oh let's go - Dante from
Florida we haven't heard from Dante for
something like five or six weeks
Dante's calls or sometimes sometimes
interesting what do you have for me
today Dante oh there's been a lot of
criticism of Trump in how he handled the
response to the corona virus and I think
that merited sorry Dante I hate it okay
do you have a son speaker or Bluetooth
or something because your connection is
not what it what it usually is today no
I okay all right go ahead Dante well
we'll keep going yeah but there isn't
really any criticism of the Democrats
and they're in there an adequate
response to the corona virus because
it's a Democrat and aunt it was a Chuck
Schumer who came out and people against
the universal basic income during the
pandemic and wanted to mean test any
payment they also came out against any
recurring payment to the people who
qualified for the original payment yes
and they also they even though Nashville
controls the house she hasn't proposed
anything to deal with the like my breath
freezes or even subsidizes friend right
there is Kiki
in the middle of the unprecedented
pandemic and economic crisis she is on
vacation she allowed the house to go on
vacation for a month and it refuses dot
remote voting so and even progresses
like a LT won't even acknowledge that
the Democrats are largely blocking the
policies that we think would be best to
deal with the crisis right so what do
you think about the plans I make is the
wife blameless there are no good guys so
what do you think about the Democrats
being led off the hook for their
terrible well again I don't know I don't
know who's necessarily letting them off
the hook let's go through each piece
my woman yeah I know the easy hold on a
second
the the vacation thing I don't know that
it's the best critique I mean listen
everybody's distancing and everybody is
in their home districts rather than in
DC and we can say it's obviously
necessary to have a remote voting system
I'm with you there I don't know that you
know Trump Trump has been pushing this
Nancy's on vacation it's like so's Mitch
McConnell right I mean so everybody's
just out of there they're only doing pro
forma sessions I don't know that that's
the right critique I think the right
critique which you're you're astutely
making is that even if a lot of this
stuff that Democrats haven't gotten
behind wouldn't have passed because
Republicans wouldn't have passed it
wouldn't we like to at least see
Democrats fight for some of this stuff
if it's supposedly in line with their
values and as you're pointing out even
aoc has been oh so the the suppose its
standard bearer on a lot of this stuff
has been silent on a lot of it so I
think you're quickly figuring out why I
have been saying for years none of these
people should be deified doesn't matter
who it is whether it's Pelosi or Bernie
or AOC or whoever once you are elected
you change everybody changes it doesn't
mean that they're bad people it doesn't
mean anything but it means exactly what
you're pointing out which is there's a
lot of blame to go around here for not
doing enough and what do you think do
you think that whoever try to adopt
these policies or do you think that they
discuss-- go along with everything that
the Republican four fold to deal with
the crisis like they went along with the
the multi trillion dollar corporate
bailout that was their first priority
yes my dude even I do you think they
would ever do anything to help direct
people or do you think that it's gonna
leave everybody hi listen I am not naive
enough to think that I can tell you
whether they will ever do something if
this extends imagine that the current
situation extends eight months I think
what you will see elected officials be
willing to do would be very different
than if we're able to start loosening
things in six to eight weeks so I don't
I don't know I just
don't know the answer to that I wouldn't
pretend to know all right Dante great to
hear from you Dante has been calling in
for a while and it's always great to
hear from him let's take a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we will go directly back to the phones
after this very short break